just can't get enough of ryan reynolds
today apparently we're gonna watch
ryan reynolds signing biggest mcu deal
in
history bigger than rdj's deadpool
i don't know what exactly this
information is entailed i don't know the
specifics i mean obviously the title is
you know like okay he's getting a huge
contract deal
possibly but i i don't know what any of
that means
like he's the new kevin feige it's gonna
be all his vision from here on out get
ready for
self-aware but very charming movies i'd
be
surprised if she was able to get a deal
that big
so i don't know i'm already apprehensive
going into hearing this information
uh but yeah i saw several people
reporting this we're gonna watch our our
friend warren's cosmic wonder video
oh hello i know right
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and today we have some
major mcu news let's see possibly
some of the biggest news in mcu history
according to a recent report that came
out last night
now i know i don't know from where on
sundays but i'm doing this video on
saturday night because this
is insane news and we're putting this up
monday
afternoon everybody is just absolutely
excited for him to finally enter the mcu
and everybody is wondering when
and it seems like we're going to find
that out relatively soon as there has
been a report that ryan reynolds is in
talks with marvel studios
right now to sign one of the biggest
deals in marvel history
now this report is coming from daniel
richmond of course
and a lot of the scoops in the past have
been raped that is
true and last night on his patreon
account he posted this scoop
marvel cco kevin feige is interested in
wanting to sign deadpool star
ryan reynolds to the biggest deal in mcu
history
now this isn't said lightly what's the
biggest deal
it's a big deal but the impact on the
mcu it could have
is insanely big as well now just to put
this in perspective for you
robert downey jr initially agreed to
four
movies three iron man movies and an
avengers movie then of course his
contract was renegotiated he was also an
incredible
ultimately he would end up appearing in
nine mcu films
iron man iron man 2 the avengers iron
man 3
avengers age of ultron captain america
civil war
spider-man homecoming avengers infinity
war and avengers end game
so did i mention the hulk you know it's
an underappreciated
film bigger than robert downey jr
that means that ryan reynolds is going
to sign up for
potentially 10 or more mcu films
it so no doubt that that is not playing
deadpool
however that doesn't mean that they
won't use him for other potential roles
for example he could play deadpool but
he could do the voice over for another
character but if we think about
just who deadpool is it would actually
make sense for
marvel to throw him in a bunch of
different mcu movies without giving him
his own deadpool movies at the same time
if there's anybody that can hop through
the multiverse
that's when he should have showed up
mcu but with deadpool you can do things
that you can't normally do in other
words and that's because
deadpool breaks the fourth wall there's
nothing that's like home
and i share that home with someone you
met the old blind lady from the
laundromat
al god i miss cocaine
huh fourth wall break inside a fourth
wall break
that's like 16 walls
[Laughter]
i forgot that much
in the x-men film as well and then at
the end if marvel decides to do secret
wars
he'll be there as well so that's five
movies right there and then they could
sprinkle them in the mcu and other
different movies here and there
throughout time which is something i
think nobody would have a problem with
absolutely at all so in future videos
we'll talk
about how i have such a hard time
believing that they would want
such an enormous deal like that
perhaps you can enter for a chance to
win a cyclops funko pop
i'm picking a winner on monday don't
forget to like the video and you can
follow me on instagram it looks like a
cool funko pop
and as always it's monday you should win
you're still here
it's over go home
we are home yeah too late and it's been
over three hours since i shot that free
guy reaction
and they're still going to town out
there fairly
it's today's the day they're going to
get this one bush
sir daniel sutton really appreciates you
sharing what he's got exclusively on his
patreon page
yeah it's a patreon exclusive let me
just transfer this information to my
youtube video
so is this guy just running a patreon
page in which he just gives you
very very deep cut and fragile news
maybe i don't know if we got to pledge
this patreon page now then we could
mirror awards
we could be more just sharing this guys
what does he put it at 12 30 1 30
usually
we should we just gotta do it one minute
before he puts it up there you go and
just launch a silent war on the cosmic
wonder
why not i appreciate this video warm you
know we love you dude the only reason
we're
yanking your chain is because you're an
actual friend we only compliment the
people
yeah i of course believe ryan reynolds
is going to be in the mcu undoubtedly
there will no doubt
be him there as deadpool like if
you freaking get jamie foxx electro
you're going to get deadpool all right
so that's not the far-fetched part to me
the far-fetched part to me is them
wanting such a huge
deal with him especially because out of
everything that we've heard about how
kevin feige likes to run his mcu
ship this is all speculation and yes
this daniel gentleman who's last time
i'm forgetting
is obviously more of a credible inside
source than i've ever been but it's
still speculation at the end of the day
and on my side of this whole theory
that he would be getting this enormous
deal i feel like kevin feige would want
to make sure they
could properly pull off deadpool 3 first
and pull off a couple of cameo
appearances because
him appearing in all the other marvel
movies
that sounds like the right step and
sounds like a blast
i think it'd be fine if he's appearing
in pg-13 movies
that are not a deadpool film but you
still got to keep the deadpool movies
rated r but you're also you know you're
this is the first time he's
he's inheriting an actual character with
the same actor
from a different established universe
pretending and i don't know what the
hell the crazy stuff is that they're
doing you know you're hearing all kinds
of weird rumors now with marvel like the
craziest rumors
of you know tom cruise is going to play
iron man and multiverse of madness here
do it emily blunt is black widow they're
trying to you know get hugh jackman to
make an appearance
it's all rumors this is like crazy
rumors that we're hearing
do i believe ron arnold's going to be as
back as deadpool of course i do
will bmcu connected of course but to
offer him such an
enormous deal bigger than robert downey
jr's
that just sounds a little far-fetched to
me even he had to prove himself for a
while and then this deal just kept
getting even bigger
this is something that we're like oh we
just inherited ryan reynolds was dead
here did a gold mine
he's such a specific tonal kind of
character too
because i feel like that would having
him in even as just a at a
like a co-star role in one of these
movies like whatever hulk was for
thor ragnarok in a way if if that or if
it's just a cameo i don't know
well that's the thing is i mean to me i
i immediately have to
question what the enormity of the
contract the deal whatever
actually is because am i thinking here
that it's only more enormous than robert
downey jr is because he gets
theoretically one more movie or is it
that they're going to pay him a whole
lot more or something like that i mean
they probably would pay him a lot of
money yeah they probably will have a lot
of money i mean i don't know
how ryan reynolds stacks up
comparatively to rdj
now but the thing that yeah that i would
wonder most of all
is does this imply that we're gonna do
10-ish
deadpool or deadpool plus the avenger
movies because what seems
more likely to me is i absolutely agree
that marvel would want to
see what their approach to a deadpool
movie
is and how to make that work within the
structure they've already established
and whatnot
and it seems very likely that you could
have you know maybe three out of these
ten movies at least be
deadpool projects but the thing about
deadpool is that he can also pop
up anywhere for any length of time and
so part of me wonders if it's just yeah
we're gonna have you in a minimum of a
lot of movies and some of those might be
small appearances some of those might be
medium appearances and a couple of them
will be your own movie or something yeah
because he is a character that to me
especially adding him now into the mcu
he seems almost like the one character
who can exist within and also outside of
everything and so it it opens up a lot
of possibility but also a lot of
a lot of possibility and so like you
know some of that uh
sounds really cool to me and some of it
sounds like yeah we're maybe getting a
little ahead of ourselves just because
we know deadpool is right now reliably
lovable
i just it just doesn't strike me as a
maneuver kevin feige would want to do
with a character and actor that he
inherited people have demanded like
charlie cox and he's just
like written that off you know yeah well
no i don't know now that they're having
all these spider-man multiverse and
everybody multiverse of madness
people are starting to talk again about
like well maybe they'll bring the
netflix heroes back
anything seems possible right to offer
him the deal that's bigger than robert
downey jr's i feel like that makes him
now the star of the mcu
that's how it feels and he might be you
know arguably
the most popular character well he's one
of the most popular characters within
marvel
right now absolutely i just don't think
they want to shh like
suddenly make him the star of the mcu
it'll take the charm away part of
i think the charm of deadpool is that he
can and does exist
on the fringes of what is established
and
you know the norm or the you know major
thing we're doing right now part of him
is to exist to poke fun at that not to
necessarily
guide it intentionally as the head of
the mcu or something
i'd just be curious to know what all the
details are you know so
i don't know if the payday will be a lot
bigger than robert downey jrs because he
gets
he made so much money uh the guy could
retire right now
brian reynolds you know you you cannot
recast him he will be
in here yeah i don't know
he's a little far-fetched to be here at
the moment but we'll see we'll see it's
exciting it's exciting thing and
hey if i'm wrong i'm wrong i don't care
just commentating on it that's all
uh what do you guys think do you guys
believe this leave your thoughts down
below subscribe to cosmic under
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified
whenever i got a new youtube video up
last but not least
jn valente i thought of you whilst
watching this video because if there's
anyone involved in our little circle of
people who seems like they live in a
perpetual
fourth wall break it is you my friend
you
are the deadpool of the real rejects
universe half the time i'm reading the
things you have to say i am tickled
i am a little uncomfortable and i am
very very
engrossed and that is how i feel whilst
watching deadpool
i'm delighted by your presence and i
hope that you get a 10 picture deal
somewhere
to guide your own cinematic universe
because i have a feeling it'll be the
most unique thing
any of us will ever see in our lives so
love you buddy
and be well pieces
very good thanks man uh i did this
mostly for you actually just to gain
your approval i don't care
jan really but i'm
glad you said that
don't believe this piece of news gasps
you